he's Kevin Frazier Entertainment Tonight
co-host and he joins us now live from
London K Frey thanks for joining us
where are you right as we speak
VP I'm standing right across from PM
palace with our loyal expert Katie
Mikkel who is on feeling as though
everything that's happening it's you
know quite the scene right now how many
people are out there I'd say there's
about 400 people around mulling around
hope but I think Williams just rolled
into [ __ ] alanine back of a Jaguar
are they riding around town so
everybody's around people are doing
things dance
oh the royal family they nothing stops
the royal family they're always moving
always going okay here is our question
would you rather be Prince Harry Prince
Harry or Russell Wilson would you rather
be Prince Harry or Russell Wilson yeah i
you want to be Prince Harry
Russell Wilson there's a cap on his
career Harry goes forever
I mean it's until he they put him in the
ground he's the man wait have you seen
Lance you know he's got Sierra he's
gonna have more money and he doesn't you
know he doesn't have to go any of those
silly more money than Harry Harry
doesn't have any money
family does Harry has money wait a
minute ho I'm gonna settle this right
now
okay Katie Naggar loyal expert [ __ ]
clean how much money does Harry have
because the impact this American great
radio show Wow she said he's sitting on
17 million owned land eventually he'll
inherit land Boni
yeah but Russ doesn't have to go to any
of those silly ceremonies that that
Harry's gonna have to do that okay Katie
well city to [ __ ] on hair she told on
holic Katie
explain to him why hairs light is better
than a NFL quarterbacks life hello okay
I think hello I think I think Prince
Harry's gonna pull the trump card on
this because he gets
in a palace he's probably not as much
money but he's got you've got a lot to
you a lot for tea not these a very
attractive actress he's about to marry
on Saturday so at the moment I agree
he's the man of the moment okay Katie
let me put it in your language here
would you rather be Prince Harry or
David Beckham I'd rather be Prince Harry
four days to be honest I don't really
want to be either of them but if I think
one I want Harry today because I'd
really love to know what goes on in
every corner of the palace Beckham has
been in the palace yes but he doesn't
get to go to most important rooms the
Queen jewelry he get back like no one
else
all right well thank you Katie sorry any
day thank you it's so cheery over there
tell me that how much do you love that I
mean it makes you happy when you just
stand next to someone who talks like
that
they're always cheering they're always
tearing cheerio yeah of course of course
of course she's Terry she covers the
Royals for a living do you remember ever
interviewing Megan Markel before she
became you know yes yes and I'll tell
you I'll tell you a great story about
hmm at the Super Bowl just before you're
you know the game the beach the beach
football game yeah they were doing the
river enjoyed a lot the beach ball yes
he was in yeah remember the beach ball
so we're there we're getting ready for
the beach ball Megan Markel comes down
carpet you know and I turn around and
I'm like hmm is this girl so it takes a
minute for me to even click in to
understand who it is and at work we're
talking and all of a sudden Selena pops
on the carpets
now you know we're standing on the red
carpet and our producers wanted to move
along they start pushing you in the back
because they start poking cokie and
they're like
pokey wrap it up with this girl wrap it
up we've got to go hey we need Sarina so
literally I joke around with Megan for a
second we mean mug at the camera and
then I'm like hey thank you talking to
you and I push her along to get this
arena know
all right so that's my Megan Parker
moment I boot by the way you watching
the NBA over there yeah I understand I
have to I have to you know I have to get
up at 3:00 a.m. to watch the games but
yes I watched LeBron last night yes I
watched the rock the night before yeah
are you being told to wrap it up or do
you have to do something here and if
it's I'm hearing somebody in the
background
somebody was cited they were talking to
me is everybody's just walking around
and pasty but it's all good there where
you getting the people to UK will you
get an interview with Prince Harry
um no one will get an interview with
Prince Harry the Royals are wrapped
tighter they're like I I'm trying to
think of who because we could all get
one interview with Michael Jordan so I'm
trying to think of who the person is
that was that person who would wave at
you but keep moving hmm you know it's
very different here they'll give their
you know two interviews a year but for
the most part it's like stiff upper lip
and keep moving smiling way to get going
it's kind of will be it's a little
surprising because they you know they
wave at you but they never they're never
like and I'm coming over to talk that's
my guy over there and they're like hey
good to see you brother
and it'll be interesting to see how they
can handle that because you know she
knows how the game was played in the US
so we were yelling like Megan Megan okay
I have to hold her back at some point
now that day is over darling young any
more interviews now do they acquire her
is she is she going to be now in the
citizenship I I think she is a British
citizen now
I think she's gonna become a British
citizen but you can have dual
citizenship my wife was born in London
she has she has a you know a British
passport sort of my children so he will
she will be a British citizen
good luck with this assignment I'll be
watching your latest report your next
report tonight of course on
Entertainment Tonight my next report
tonight and then on Saturday I'll be on
CBS doing the whole wedding I want to
forget Katie will she become a British
citizen Megan she said does that mean
she has to drop everything American
she's gonna drop us there I I hear
that's a big loss yeah that's a big loss
for the team is that yes it is yeah all
right well thank you can observe operate
in exchange thank you Kevin
that's Kevin Frazier for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]